ROBINSON.
AT
TOPPIN.
YOUR EFFORT WILL HELP YOUR YOU
WANT TOAND IN
ONE, WHAT AN
>> Eric: MY SHOT?
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BLOCK E
FLUIDS ON THE FLOOR.
WOW, REGGI.
ERIC: TERRY WORKING ON I!
DELL: THAT'S THE IMPORTANCE OFF
ROOM.
>> Dan: UNFORTUNATELY NOBODTHE
SIDE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
DIME, AND >> Hubie: HE HAS SUCHE
VISIONCOLLINS,  EIGHT POINTS. L
ZERO
LAURI MARKKANEN WITH A DUNKS.
FIRST LAURI  BLAZERS
HAD TO PUT ON
>> Stan: JEFF GREEN HERE
PATTY MILLS TO MAKE HIM SEE
BODIES IN FRONT OF BOUNDS.
>> Mark: HOW HIGH THE
PAINT, AND THEN THE SPIN IN GOT.
BACK CUT FOR BONES.
SCOTT: THIS ISCONTINUITY.
PUT REAVES ON HIS KNEES AND FIR.
MITCHELL WITH THE
WAY, AND THREE MINUTES GONE BY
HERE IN THE SECOND, AND
HAS TO BE THIS
PICK UP ANOTHER.
>> Mark: OH, MAN HE TOOK HIS TA.
R
AFTER BANGER, IT HERE. OKOGIEA
NINE